top military leaders are vowing to take
action on unsafe conditions in the
military's privatized housing now CBS
News has reported extensively on this
uncovering evidence of mold rats and
major disrepair in homes where a lot of
the parents are raising their children
now five military families are taking
legal action claiming the housing at a
base in Florida cause long-term health
problems Jane Crawford is in Washington
where lawmakers grilled military chiefs
yesterday Jan good morning to you what
did we hear in that testimony well I
mean you know I mean publicly the
military is now saying enough is enough
when it comes to issues with military
housing but some might say you know
that's a little too little too late I
mean the military wise that we spoke to
said their families will live with the
health consequences for the rest of
their lives to know that you have been
living in a home that was growing mold
and it was poisoning you
it was scary some of my children will be
sick from this for the rest of their
lives it's black mold like this inside
the homes of gin Eagan rich and Amy
Norquist if they say are causing their
families to suffer from respiratory and
neurological illnesses there among five
military families suing the owners and
property managers of their privatized
housing at MacDill Air Force Base in
Florida alleging unsafe living
conditions they claim the defendants not
only failed to address the issues when
notified by residents but also denied
the existence and severity of the
problems and didn't properly share
information with residents and the
public
I saw mold on subflooring there was
black mold it was on pieces of sheetrock
and it was really terrifying and scary
to know that we had been living in this
home and we were being exposed to that
CBS News partnered with Reuters news on
an investigation this year into housing
issues at military bases across the
country as reported in the press some of
these contractors are now under
investigation for defrauding the federal
government that reporting was fuel for
senators Tuesday as they grilled top
military brass about how they're going
to hold these private housing companies
accountable
someone who served myself this pisses me
off maybe some of the CEOs need to move
into some military housing over the
holidays to military wives we spoke to
say they hope this lawsuit will prevent
more families from getting sick we're
finding just up against a giant trying
to just make sure that other people are
safe now military officials say they
have fixed problems on many of those
bases but some of the housing is in such
bad condition it's gonna have to be torn
down at that hearing the private housing
companies were called slumlords and
there's also a possibility of criminal
charges Tony all right Jane thank you
very much